[Music]
so longtime fans of this show will
remember that um last week a long time
ago we cancelled trans youtuber samantha
lux who posted a video
attacking my best-selling lgbt novel
johnny the walrus which is available for
pre-order at johnnywalrus.com after i
debunked sam's debunking many people in
the comments informed me that youtube is
in fact full of videos criticizing my
seminal work of children's literature
johnny the walrus which is available
johnnywalrus.com they wanted to know why
i only picked on good old sam
while leaving these other would-be
debunkers unscathed
well as you know i'm a big advocate for
equity and inclusion i would never want
to single anybody out unfairly or leave
or leave anybody out unfairly and so
today i'm going to go through
all the other anti-johnny the walrus
videos on the platform and cancel all of
them now we're not going to have time
unfortunately to watch all these videos
in their entirety but we'll watch a
short and hopefully representative clip
from each just so we get an idea of what
they're all about enough to demonstrate
why they deserve to be canceled
some of these videos are from accounts
with lots of subscribers some of them
have a subscriber base that includes
their immediate families and nobody else
and some probably don't even have a fan
base that large but we're gonna we're
gonna include the whole spectrum today
because i think that's that's the
fairest thing and again this is about
equity
so we begin with the youtube channel
just a lazy gamer
already you can appreciate the
self-awareness at the very least let's
see what lazy gamer has to say about uh
my book yes matt walsh has decided to
make a book
hating on trans children because you
know they've got to get that hate speech
in when they're young but here's the
thing he's also decided to do the let's
go brandon song bryson gray approach and
go hey
maybe you can get me in the top 10. and
that'll really show if you you give me
your money
and if we go to amazon
he's already got 23 ratings
no verified purchasers of course because
the book hasn't made it to anyone's
store
now this book
is on amazon amazon has rules against
hate speech
in their book they have that in the
rules
and i get the feeling he's hoping
that this book gets banned on amazon to
play the victim even more maybe after
they get it up like number 15 or
whatever on a chart
and of course he's selling signed copies
for i think it's thirty dollars with ten
dollar shipping
because of course he is because the
grifting never stops
um okay to begin with
he talks about there's a signed copies
thirty dollars for a signed copy is a
steal i'm literally the most prominent
and respected lgbt children's author in
american history as well as the
country's
leading cult leader and the most
generous philanthropist at a boiler
fundraiser of the 21st century so my
signature is worth thousands um that i'd
give it away for a measly thirty dollars
just speaks again to my generosity not
to mention my humility
furthermore i i take a great exception
to the claim that we wanted to get
banned from amazon after reaching number
15 on the chart that's absurd
we wanted to get banned after reaching
the top five
we did get to the top five but we didn't
get banned instead we just got banned
from target which was a rather sort of
disappointing um runner-up prize finally
the book does not hate on trans kids
primarily because there's no such thing
as trans kids
my issue is with the adults who have
invented the category of trans kids
so if i'm hating on anyone it's them
because they're morally debased child
abusers hopefully that clears that up
now we have youtuber sam collins sam has
a larger presence on youtube over 800
000 subscribers let's see what sam has
to offer
and a simple procedure cuts feet into
fins
the doctor wants to cut
into johnny and make him into a walrus
ah there it is the whole mutilation
thing because we chop ourselves up
remember when we have surgeries we're
mutilating ourselves and we're chopping
ourselves up it's also funny because
this book is about a child and i've said
it over and over again and many trans
people have said that children don't get
surgeries we could say it a thousand
times but these people still just choose
not to believe what we say it's really
funny because this can be explained with
just one simple thought children don't
get surgery right how would you ever
have a surgery when you're not fully
developed anyways you can't
cut this off if it's not there so please
explain to me how these children are
getting surgeries
uh happily i'll explain it a few points
here first
no i don't think that when trans people
have surgery they're mutilating
themselves
because if you have a trans person who
has gallbladder surgery or gets their
acl repaired or has heart surgery
i wouldn't call that mutilation
surgeries that are meant to treat
medical issues are not mutilation no
matter who's getting them
but a surgery that destroys a healthy
body part or that slices open a healthy
organ and flips it inside out
is mutilation no matter who's getting it
by definition that's mutilation now if
you don't believe me let's go to the
dictionary mutilation here's the the
definition an act or instance of
destroying removing or severely damaging
a limb or other body part of a person or
animal
so what happens to the penis during a
sex chain surgery
what happens to a woman's breasts during
top surgery
these parts of the body are either
removed or destroyed
they are by definition mutilated
there's no denying this
now as for the claim that children don't
get these procedures that is for one
thing a lie
minor girls do in fact have their
breasts removed it's very common happens
all the time minor boys have even had
their penises mutilated that also
happens
but even if that weren't happening
still children are being conditioned to
make those choices quote-unquote later
on in life they're being put on that
path even though they don't understand
the path they're on
and even if most boys aren't being
physically altered through surgery they
are being given puberty blockers like
lupron which is chemical castration
the same drug used to chemically
castrate sex offenders so your argument
sam is that the boys aren't being
surgically castrated they're just being
chemically castrated
and even that argument as insane as it
is
is also factually wrong
the truth is that both things are
happening
now we turn to uh youtuber justin justin
freaking the guy's uh you know he's a
formidable voice in the culture he has
uh 6 000 subscribers averages easily
over 30 views per video and his channel
description promises quote uncensored
and unfiltered political talk and debate
from a leftist perspective the day's top
news stories and videos with astute
social commentary
i'm not sure if we can trust the part of
the social the part about you know
astute social commentary i don't know
about that we'll find out in a minute
but we can be confident that it's
uncensored
if this guy's a leftist then certainly
we can be assured that he has not been
censored so let's bring let's see what
he brings to the table
not as insane as matt walsh from the
daily wire releasing the children's book
here is matt walsh apparently
getting some children together
for story hour
with sweet baby matt walsh
okay
hello boys and girls yeah the kids look
about as enthused as we are he didn't
draw the
cartoons and that's the main part of the
book
like
passing yourself off as the author of
this stupid book is insane because you
know what this book is this book is a
actual talented illustrator
and then some dumb words on top of it
honestly i don't know why this guy
doesn't get more views i mean he's like
macho man randy savage
if macho man randy savage
could only bench press 45 pounds
and was a hippie
but randy has exposed a startling truth
that i did not illustrate my own
children's book i have tried to keep
this hidden
by putting the illustrator's name on the
cover i was hoping to hide it in plain
sight and my plan almost worked until
seth rogen's unemployed cousin foiled
the plot
um all right let's finish this up with a
with a somewhat larger account this is
uh val shervash i don't know how to
pronounce his name 386 thousand
subscribers his video is titled matt
walsh reads his new anti-trans book to
kids and i am incredibly uncomfortable
and the video's done pretty well for us
got nearly 150 000 views let's skip
ahead to i think what is i guess the
crux of his argument against my book
wait what is the lesson at the wait so
wait now is he bird gender wait what is
the
what does any of this mean
what what does any of this mean man
uh no he said earlier people online told
his mom a well-meaning mother was duped
by evil transgender sj that was yeah
yeah okay but like what about the kid
like the kid didn't seem after the kids
said i am a walrus
and had a picture taken of him the kid
had no input whatsoever did the kid want
to eat the worms if not why didn't he
stop what was was the kid like i don't
want to eat the worms and the mom was
like no you have to the people on
instagram said that you have to or i'm a
bit like
i i i don't want to dig into this too
hard because it's obviously really
stupid but i am genuinely astounded by
the incompetence with which this was put
together like they paid an artist they
had it published like it's on sale like
how do you not put a little more effort
not even just the quality of the art but
like the language used betrays such an
incredible incompetence in using
allegory to deliver a political message
that's true i'm not good with language i
mean we can't all be wordsmiths like
valshar who says things like the
language used betrays such an incredible
incompetence in using allegory to
deliver a political message
dude why do you speak in real life like
you're a ninth grader writing a book
report trying to hit a minimum word
count
you think it's a bad allegory just say
that
though i'm not sure how you could judge
the competence of the story or the
allegory considering you by you're on a
mission don't understand the point
you're a grown adult who failed to grasp
the extremely simple message in a
rhyming children's book written on
cardboard for preschoolers
and somehow you think that your failures
of reading comprehension are an
embarrassment to me
i mean i am embarrassed watching this
but the embarrassment is of the second
hand variety i assure you
the good news is that um
you seem to have almost understood the
point so you got to the 10-yard line
intellectually before you fumble the
mental football
you nearly made it all the way there
because you note how in the story the
mom is the focus while the child johnny
has little input
into his own alleged lifestyle choice
he's doing things he's walking down a
certain path but it doesn't really seem
like he's he's choosing to go in that
direction
yes vaush that's the point
that that's exactly the point
that's what we're going for
the fact that johnny's mommy is really
the main character
in a story that's ostensibly about
johnny himself is not an accident
that's a bit of intentional irony
very much an intentional creative
decision
by the brilliant author of this book
which is available at johnnywalrus.com
it's almost as if
i'm trying to make the point
that transgenderism among children is
once again an event in invention of the
adults around them no child can actually
choose this path they don't have the
psychological and emotional formation
required to make an informed decision
about fundamentally altering their
identities
any child therefore who does make such a
decision decision quote unquote has been
by definition pushed and pulled that way
by the grown-ups in their lives
do you understand now
because i literally can't make it any
simpler or plainer than that
the book is written at a reading level
for kids who barely know how to read
so if that's still above your
intellectual pay grade i'm afraid
there's not much else i can do
except say
that you're cancelled
along with fake randy savage sam collins
the rest of the youtube hordes who have
all tried and failed to take down my
book johnny the walrus which is
available for sale at johnnywalrus.com
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated